required that you could probably tell us
even better than I could it required the
you know the OSI within the Department
of Justice people to really kind of
create this new paradigm for bringing
these trials forward I mean typically
you have prosecutors working with
investigators who do kind of normal
investigative work and then they help
develop these case and in this case it
simply would not work
I mean you needed people who were first
of all you need people with language
skills most of the information most of
the evidence was in a foreign language
so typical investigator who have no
ability whatsoever to negotiate with
these kind of documents and so the OSI
and you're one of the living examples of
this they pioneered this completely
unprecedented arrangement within the
Department of Justice that is they
basically get rid of all their normal
investigators and they hire professional
historians and the OSI looks like in
advance you know an Institute for the
Advanced Study of the Holocaust
I mean you end up having you and your
colleagues end up being kind of this
really remarkable team that works
closely with lawyers for the purposes of
mastering the incredible the difficult
documentary evidentiary and historical
challenges that arise out of these cases
of course one thing that the OSI also
learned the hard way was the
difficulties of relying on eyewitness
testimony I mean again this is something
it came up in the Damania case it also
comes up in another case that you're
familiar with this this Wallis case
which actually came before that some
young guys but and you can imagine how
difficult is you know you have these
witnesses who swear with absolute
certainty
so you could see the way in which
lawyers would be tempted to believe that
the people who had suffered such a
trauma were accurate in the
identifications but ultimately they came
to realize that as drys that maybe that
documentary evidence ultimately was more
solid than the identification of
eyewitnesses so the dim Janiak case and
it moves on to germany why did germany
decide to prosecute him over 60 years
after his crime
and what was the significance of that
case
yeah so a lot of people thought so just
to be clear dummy on you he was not a
Nazi right and he was not a German this
is a guy who was originally he was from
the Ukraine was born in the Ukraine in
1920 he was actually taken as a prisoner
of war by the Vama by the German army in
the spring of 1942 and demonic is
someone who you know many people said
granted he might have been a
collaborator and he clearly was a
collaborator he clearly was enlisted by
the SS and collaborated and served as a
deaf camp guard at sub or not Treblinka
but there was this question about what
good are we doing by by trying someone
who by all accounts was at the bottom of
this experiment or E hierarchy and who
was never announced he never a and
certainly was not a German and when I
started I wrote about this a trial first
for Harper's Magazine and when I first
started writing about it I have to say I
thought the trial was going to be
somewhat grotesque and I thought my
conclusion was going to be what are they
doing trying this guy seven years after
the fact and by the end of the trial I
came to the realization that this was an
incredibly important trial important
trial because in many ways this is a
trial that got the logic of genocide
right that is it understood it kind of
got went back to the point that ad
ensign had made when you're talking
about the common plan under spout made
the same point about a number of people
made this the same point earlier but
German courts had for decades treated
the Holocaust as if it were a
garden-variety act of murder just
multiplied millions of times over and
the great achievement of this trial that
took place between 2009 2011 is it
really understood the genocide is not
like murder when you're dealing with
state-sponsored mass criminality it
doesn't matter if someone's particularly
cruel it doesn't matter if someone's a
sociopath or say it is if someone worked
in a factory of death they were an
accessory to murder because that was
their job and that was the simple and
yet historic kind of breakthrough of the
German Court took them sixty years to
frame that relatively simple and
straightforward conclusion but it's a
critical conclusion not only for making
sense of the Holocaust but also making
sense of other instances of
state-sponsored atrocity and that's why
we still have these remaining trials
today because it's basically operating
on the assumption the conclusion of the
process that you you have why and why
try someone was ninety five four years
old obviously seventy years after the
war they it's on that logic that you
don't have to prove a particular murder
if they and and and every trial
established that there were options
usually people did not have to do these
jobs they were not no consequences for
instance you opted out of the
Einsatzgruppen so these trials were
seeing today is to make that point now
the irony is of course if that same
logic were used in the 50s and 60s then
hundreds of thousands would have been on
trial and theory and so but at least the
point is made and that obeying an order
is just saying I obey orders is never an
acceptable defense in some ways it's the
worst worst defense you can have in fact
actually if I may just ever I think we
need to think it give people a chance to
ask okay one pointed point that Andy
made which i think is one of the most
interesting things to come out from
Holocaust research which was many of the
people who were put on trial argued that
the reason they engage in these
manifested criminal acts is because they
were forced to that is that they
basically had a gun to their head and
that's why they engage in these mass
atrocities well historians have spent a
huge amount of time looking into that
claim and the total number of SS men or
German NCOs who suffered serious
draconian consequences as a result of
opting out and there were people opted
out maybe not as many as we like but
there were people opted out the total
number of people who suffered draconian
consequences is exactly zero
great well I know this is we could talk
for a long time there are a lot of
interesting aspects to this subject and
I'm sure that many of you would like to
ask some questions we have mics down at
either end here I can't see
unfortunately but if you want to line up
yeah it's a little bit better and you
can ask your questions so the night
asked a please that you keep them pretty
specific I think we'll take a few
questions and then meet them out
yuria I was just wondering do you think
the focusing on the female perpetrators
which are always kind of scandalous like
Koch or branch done or even Costello
Gaulish luck that that's in a way
diverted the attention from this wider
span of the criminality that's that's I
hate to use the word banal but is is
where nobody's responsible everybody's
just a function now there isn't this
personal element of cruelty great can
you take another professor another
question yeah yes
I wonder people talk a little bit more
about the Einsatzgruppen because in a
sense take one's country like Lithuania
not one
Unser's group in commander has ever been
put on trial in the few a Nia and 98% of
the Iranian Jews were murdered in three
months I'd like to hear a little bit
more about what you have to say about
that okay you know we have one more
question yeah I was curious about the
trials I've been reading about in
Germany today of these 90 some year old
Nazis that have suddenly the Germans
have decided to prosecute and convict
can you talk a minute about that
yeah I mean I'm happy to answer that
last question about and maybe I'll
answer a couple so that the trouser take
it one trial these um Reinhold tonic is
actually the trial of Chanukah is
actually going on right now
in Germany and this past summer obscure
gronic the so called bookkeeper of
Auschwitz he was convicted this past
July and both of these trials were
basically building on the demonic
precedent in fact one of the things that
some of the people who had a somewhat
cynical reaction to the Jimmy Aine trial
was isn't it ironic that the Germans
finally have this great conceptual
breakthrough when there's no more
perpetrators even to bring to trial so I
think one of the things that the German
prosecutors were interested in doing was
trying to show well at least we're going
to try to use in the time
remains to us we're going to try to use
this precedent as an opportunity to go
after some of the remaining guards were
live and again I think the point of
these childs is it's in fact many of the
survivors and the family of survivors
who go who have attended these trials I
think they're really interested in
seeing the symbolic statement of a
conviction I think they're less
interested in seeing nonagenarian be
sent away for the rest of his days as
much as they're interested in seeing the
symbolic understanding that this person
was an accessory to murder because that
was the job that he was performing and
to connect that point to the question
about the female perpetrators and the
people like this a call and I do think
those kind of trials are very misleading
they kind of they kind of fit into this
period or kind of voyeuristic
understanding of Nazi crimes as this
kind of you know ghoulishly sexualized
and I think that was the whole point
about the greatness of the demeanor
trial that the demand your trial this
was not a person who was a sociopath
this was not a person who was acting out
of like sexual deviance say this was a
entirely ordinary person in many ways he
was the banal figure that Eichmann never
was I think we now know really was a
zealous anti-semite Tim Yannick really
was kind of like a lowly foot soldier of
genocide I just add on these trials
today again just like Lawrence says it's
not so much the punishments that that's
the issue these are the last trials
where you get the perpetrator maybe
he'll actually say something but you
have who eyewitnesses still you get
testimony it's to put this on record and
that is critical and that's been
critical from the beginning and it's
interesting that someone like for
instance Fritz Bauer the German
prosecutor urban Jewish prosecutor his
first case in 1952 was a libel case
against a man by the name of Otto
Remer if some of you saw the movie
Valkyrie about the July 20th attempted
to assassinate Hitler
Remer was the guy who marched in was
supposed to arrest Goebbels thinking
that Hitler was dead he Hitler gets on
the phone says arrest the plotters but
he will but but Fritz Bower was was it
was suing him for libel not because of
that but because he said after the war
in a far-right rally that the people who
tried to assassinate Hitler were
traitors and they were foreign agents
and he won the defamation case and he
even forgot to ask for a punishment the
point was to win and to show that to be
a patriotic German meant to oppose
Hitler and that that's something again
and again in these trials were getting
to you as for the Einsatzgruppen there's
no satisfaction there anyplace I mean
been friends who is a man who said I
didn't even ask for a particular
sentence I did the crimes were so great
but he had he had documentation
basically on 3,000 people he said who
everyday would go out and shoot people
and he picked in Nuremberg there were 24
seats in that docket so he chose 24 at
first then two of them dropped out for a
couple reasons so he tried 22 and as I
mentioned only four of them were put to
death and and the rest served sentences
that were all up by 1958
so the Einsatzgruppen again it was no
more than symbolic and a lot of this
justice was symbolic but they that the
notion that at least you get the verdict
and you get at least you get the history
then that has an impact some of the
people in the Einsatzgruppen that
operated in lithuania were tried by the
West later but they ain't us griffin
we're actually very small they didn't do
all the killings themselves and that so
that's a common misses of the killings
and they'd relied very heavily on local
support wherever they went and in
Lithuania that was true there were many
Lithuanians who were involved in the
killings
and there were some trials post worry
and when Lithuania was under the Soviet
Union but after Lithuania became
independent Lithuanians
you know clung very much to this
perception of themselves as the double
victims they suffered under the Nazis
and they suffered under the Soviets and
there was a great reluctance to face up
to what some of their countrymen had
done during the Holocaust and that's a
process that they're still going through
I think there's there's been some some
progress in that but definitely not in
the form of trials and now it's probably
too late so any more questions yes I do
one of the purposes of trials
I guess hopefully would be to prevent
these kinds of incidents from happening
in the future when I look at the world
today
if anything I think the world is
becoming even more brutal and more
engaged in genocides than it ever was
before and I was just wondering what
your feelings are about these trials and
the roles that they play in terms of
changing the way people feel about
genocide and more important acting on
those feelings
well the acting is the hard part
and obviously we haven't done too well I
mean you look at Rwanda look at Cambodia
any number of situations but I think
what has changed is the principle now I
think even every tyrant and somewhere
somewhere in his mind is a thought if if
if I'm no longer in power somebody may
may charge me with war crimes or crimes
against humanity and that was not a
concern before and to me it's also it's
a bit like also the stories you know
there are a lot of myths about Nazi
hunters not just about Israelis but
about about Nazi hunters like Wiesenthal
remember the boys from Brazil hunting
down a Mengele type character in Latin
America well some of that myth actually
people like Mengele who escaped justice
the hiding and be sort of living in
terror at the end of their days so maybe
some myths are not all bad but in terms
of the the principles are have been
established the reality is still a long
a long way from it but I think that that
is a breakthrough and and again could
get back to the principle to say that
I'm obeying orders when clearly orders
are you are meant every individual has
to judge those orders and it's like
during the Einsatzgruppen case at one
point the judge my judgment mano asked
one of the most educated Einsatzgruppen
leaders if if someone if you had been
ordered to shoot your own sister will
you have shot your own sister and it
suddenly left him speechless because you
know What did he say if he says I'd
shoot my own sister you know I said
comes across really like a monster but
if he says I wouldn't then he undermines
this whole whole idea that I didn't have
any free will here yeah the question you
raised is really a question about
deterrence and in my own mind deterrence
is not a particularly strong
justification for international
prosecutions if you look for example at
the charter of the International
Criminal Court which is now a permanent
institution which is meant to supplant
the need for creating these kind of
ad-hoc courts like Nuremberg Nuremberg
was an ad hoc court disbanded after the
trial was concluded all of these
international tribunals they always talk
about deterrence as one of their
justifications but if you talk to any
international lawyer no one takes that
seriously no one really believes that
these kind of trials are gonna
necessarily deter some tyrant in some
far-flung country from engaging in
atrocities against his own population
but nonetheless as Andy pointed out that
doesn't necessarily impeach the
importance of these cases that is they
make a symbolic statement that these
type of atrocities will not result in
impunity and the other thing that they
do is this goes back to something that
Andy had mentioned and that
I've written about as well is that these
trials perform an incredibly important
function in offering in a count that is
in offering and story of the history of
tragedy which then can be assimilated by
both a victim population and also a
country that perpetrate such crimes and
I think that's more of the value of
these cases these kind of trials rather
than a prospective deterrent effect not
to mention the fact that deterrence is
always a speculative thing it's hard to
prove why something didn't happen all
right I mean that's always an impossible
thing to prove but I wouldn't
necessarily justify my first order in
that regard okay do you have time for
[Music]
question though apart from genocide
there is a decreasing prevailing
anti-semitism particularly in Europe in
France in which the word leaf is
becoming pervasively used and
particularly one of the great ally
Britain in England the Labour Party now
is full of anti-semitism as I read
recently at least 50 members of
parliament have been suspended because
of anti-semitic remarks the new Muslim
mayor of London this is the most the one
of the strongest opponents of this
anti-semitism is calls for the expulsion
of Ken Livingstone the former mayor of
like formerly but his mythological still
belief that or assertion that the
Zionists worked with Hitler that Hitler
was a Zionist that was the claim yes
yeah and so I'm wondering whether
notwithstanding we don't have the
genocide we don't have the that kind of
horror the pervasive increasing
anti-semitism that is rampant in Europe
with our former allies his evidence that
lessons really
not been learned I can't argue with that
all I would say is that we lessons would
be even less learned if we hadn't had
the efforts of these people who really
kept this issue alive and and and
brought made the Holocaust such a part
of the conversation that was not
inevitable there was nothing inevitable
about it any of these trials could have
could not it wouldn't necessarily have
taken place if there hadn't been
pressure on governments if there hadn't
been successful operations but there is
in Europe definitely and it's also mixed
in with the Muslim immigration problem
sometimes people fearing to do speak up
when when for instance in in France
French Jews are afraid in certain areas
of being attacked so the the whole issue
of silence in the face of that such
anti-semitism I'm glad you brought up
the new Mayor of London I mean it's been
very impressive how he stood up to
within his own party and it's good that
there are at least some actions have
been taken but our knowledge of history
I mean you had Boris Jordan the the
former mayor of London who just called
the EU something akin to the efforts by
Napoleon and Hitler to unify Europe yeah
it's a little astounding that we still
have these discussions yeah yeah I mean
I think another thing that it highlights
is it does highlight the way in which
you know on some level the creation of
international criminal law over the last
half-century is a terrifically
important breakthrough and in fact you
can in many ways see the whole field of
what we call international criminal law
as something that's borne out of the
laws contact with the crimes of the
Holocaust at the same time international
criminal law is incredibly vulnerable to
politicization it's incredibly
vulnerable to be used for political ends
and so at the same time that it's
incredibly important to see people who
are being prosecuted for genocide it's
also alarming to see the way in which
prosecutors in different countries can
also claim that well that should
justified than the prosecution of an
Israeli head of state for crimes against
humanity
the Palestinian people so I think it
highlights the way in which this thing
that we call international criminal law
as important as it is is also a little
bit of a double-edged sword well thank
you everybody our two authors will be
out front
so their books will be on sale I can say
personally they're both really engaging
reads and they've been getting great
reviews so come out and ask some more
questions and buy some books
do you want to watch this program again
visit book TV org to watch any of the
programs you see here online type the
author name or book title in the search
bar at the top of the page and click the
looking glass' you can also share any of
the videos on our website by clicking
the Facebook Twitter or share icons on
the bottom right of the video box book
TV since 1998 all the top nonfiction
authors and books all available at book
TV org
Bob Lyle is a publisher of live right
which is a division WW Norton the oldest
independent and America what kind of
books you public mainly serious con
fiction and some literary fiction books
with a little edge to them books that
can change the culture well we're here
to talk to you about some of the books
that are coming out this fall and let's
start with this serious one called rat
effed rat effed is by David daily and
rat F tells the story of how the country
has been redistricted since 2010 to
shift all these congressional districts
over to Republican base most of the
architects of the BAP attune program
have spoken with the author and he's
traveled these districts and you'll see
districts go for 30 miles like
Michigan's 14th ends in a garbage to
talk dump in Pontiac Michigan and it
shows how these districts were created
the were draft F was used by Edmund
Wilson as early as the 1920s now we're
being polite in our use of the word but
the whole word is on on the front of the
book isn't it no the whole world the
whole word is not rat-fucked is not on
the front of the book there to Astra's
and we call it for the air we call it
rat F but it was used by Woodward and
Bernstein it's a long-standing word to
connote political espionage and dirty
tricks and sabotage it's by David Daly
who's head of salon another book that
did come out already but it was a
finalist for the Pulitzer marching home
is just out in paperback first book by a
brilliant young historian and it details
what happened to all the veterans when
they came to the north how they were
forgotten
the research is one of a kind and it was
just so unusual to get a finalist for
the Blitzer we are very proud of the
butter who is windy Warren and what does
she really warn there are a lot of young
exciting historians in America Wendy
Warren is a historian at Princeton she
has rewritten our 17th century the 1600s
in America she shows how slavery was
indelibly linked to the founding of
America 50 70 percent of the ships
coursing out of the New England harbors
Boston New Haven Providence all were you
know going to the West Indies the
Caribbean she shows how many of the
founding fathers like Winthrop invested
heavily in slave shipping and in ship
shipping in general John Winthrop city
on a hill his fall and his son was in
Barbados in 1928
excuse me 16 26 and not for tourism he
was there for I assume he was there
checking out the land checking out you
know what props could be produced there
his father John Winthrop only came over
four years later
Wendy Warren has written a major work
Shirley Jackson who was Shirley Jackson
Shirley Jackson is there's a huge
Renaissance she's one of the architects
in fiction of horror quality fiction in
this country she's um Ruth Franklin who
was the author of this biography says
she's the heir apparent to Poe and to
Hawthorne and she's traced this woman's
life through her novels in the 50s and
it predates feminine mystique and it's
just stunning biography why have a lot
of us not heard of her most people have
heard of her through the lottery the
lottery is one of the most famous short
stories written appeared in The New
Yorker in 1948 she was forgotten
suddenly you know America's filled with
fiction revivals and she is suddenly all
over the place there's a novel that's
coming out by Alan Moore what is this
book Bob it's one of the hottest novels
in the world including in America it's
coming out in September Alan Moore's
fame mostly as a graphic novelist but
this is a text novel which he's worked
on 20 years he'll is a her aromatic a
hermit like existence in North Hampton
in
and he's written this story of life and
fate and the story of one family over
1012 centuries and it's really this
Joyce like epic and it's getting crowds
of people New York or everyone is good
be one of the monster works of fiction
of this year and it's called Jerusalem
and it's 1200 plus page it is Jerusalem
it's named after a poem by William Blake
and it's really the story of life and a
family and mysteries and universe and
it's just I think it's a work of fiction
that will last for a hundred years Alan
Moore also V for victory has a huge huge
fan base Watchmen and you're going to
see an explosion of interest in his work
is it about the city of Jerusalem is it
Facebook Jerusalem it's about the
underclasses of Northampton England but
it's taken Jerusalem was written by
William Blake and is about the poor
people of England in the 1600s and he's
transposed to Northampton the characters
would remind you of a lot of the
characters of Joyce's Ulysses it's a
very ambitious exciting book with yarrow
and it says I think it will explode
couple more books from live right we
want to share with you that are coming
up Eric J Dolan I think Eric J Dolan a
lot of people in your audience know of
him he has written a three century
fourth century history of lighthouses
starting with the Boston Lighthouse even
until today what has happened to
lighthouse he tells the story of America
through the lighthouses what they did in
war who the lighthouse keepers were oh
you know technology versus old-fashioned
it's it's a riveting book which is I
think for anyone traveling there
hundreds of lighthouses around like
Michigan I mean you wouldn't know where
they are in America it tells the story
through a most unusual source and who
doesn't like a lighthouse
Janene DiGiovanni is one of the most
renowned war correspondents in the world
she is everywhere where there's great
danger going on this book is just out
the morning they came for us and it's
all about what happened in Syria the
prose is vivid it is a remarkable story
of one courageous war correspondents
efforts to portray a country which is
under siege and has been ruined by boil
we don't cover many novels on book TV
but we have covered this author Winston
groom several times well this is his
mace his first major novel since Forrest
Gump
it's based on years of research
especially anyone who loved trains will
love it in any American history of the
early 20th century and he takes you
through these East Coast's
industrialists and barons who have to
come down south to protect their
property against Pancho via it's great
roaring page turning fiction for anyone
who really loves American history wants
to see the intersection of history and
fiction in vivid historical characters
Bob whale is a publisher at live right
those are some of the books coming out
by that company book TV is on Twitter
follow us to get publishing news
scheduling updates author information
and to talk directly with authors during
our live programs twitter.com slash
book TV
James trial is a contributing writer for
the New York Times Magazine where he has
worked since 1998 and is a regular
columnist for foreign policy comm his
books include the best intentions coffee
and then and the UN in the era of
American world power the devil's
playground a century of pleasure and
profit in Times Square city on a hill
and the freedom agenda in his review of
John Quincy Adams militant spirit Sean
Wilentz author of the rise of American
democracy Jefferson Lincoln wrote all
right James tribes new biography of John
Quincy Adams is especially strong Adams
was a complicated hero a patrician
visionary but also as trout puts it a
militant spirit one of the most
important diplomats in all of American
history and finally slavery's greatest
enemy in American politics Rob does
justice to both the man and his times
with the historian sense of complexity
and a writer's eye for drama and detail
after his talk and question-and-answer
so when we have time Mr Trabb will be
signing copies of his book one level up
outside the National Archives store
please welcome James trial to the
National Archives
thank you very much for that
introduction so when I was coming here
this morning and I was taking the taxi
to Penn Station in New York every bus I
passed had a giant sign on the side that
said Hamilton and so naturally I thought
well what if wind Manuel Miranda the
producer and writer and star of the show
came to me and said well Jim I've done
the Hamilton hip hop thing what do you
got for me with John Quincy Adams so I
thought I need to have a story to tell
him so this is the first a book event
I've done for my book so I'm gonna tell
you the story that I would tell him if
he ever came to me to ask so on Saturday
January 21st 1842 John Quincy Adams who
was then 74 years old the former
president of the United States the
former Secretary of State a former
senator and diplomat and now a member of
the US House of Representatives of
Massachusetts decided to provoke a
confrontation with the slaveholders who
dominated the Congress for the previous
seven years Adams had waged a lonely and
often solitary struggle to protect the
right of citizens to petition Congress
for an end to slavery or to the slave
trade that right was guaranteed by the
Constitution but slaveholders resolutely
unwilling to allow the peculiar
institution to become a matter of public
debate past what was known as the gag
order to prevent such petitions from
being presented every year Adams and a
few others had presented such petitions
and every year the slaveholders and
allies among the free states had passed
a new gag order and once again in
December 1841 at the beginning of that
term of Congress the gag had been passed
and once again Adams had insisted on
testing
by bringing one petition after another
to the floor of the house under the
pretext that they did not technically
fall within the compass of the gag order
so on the 21st he presented a
particularly exacerbating such petition
the slaveholders fondly lost all
patience the abolitionist Theodore
Dwight weld wrote to his wife to
describe the scene moment which I will
now read a little excerpt from weld
Wright's wise a Virginia Rayner of North
Carolina WC Johnson of Maryland and
scores more of slaveholders striving
constantly to stop him by starting
questions of order and every now and
then screaming at the top of their
voices
that is false I demand mr. speaker
speaker that you put him down what are
we to sit here and endure such insults I
demand that you shut the mouth of that
old Harlequin that gives you a sense of
the temper of Congress in those days
a perfect uproar like Babel would burst
forth every two or three minutes as mr.
a with his bold surgery would smite his
cleaver into the very bones at least
half of the slaveholding members of the
house left their seats and gathered in
the quarter of the hall where mr. a
stood whenever any of them broke in upon
him mr. a would say I see where the shoe
pinches mr. speaker it will pinch more
yet
I'll deal out to the gentlemen a diet
they'll find it hard to digest if before
I get through every slaveholder slave
trader and slave breeder on this floor
does not get materials for a bitter
reflection it shall be no fault of mine
on Monday the 23rd atoms picked up where
he left off again reading one
anti-slavery petition after another this
time the speaker ordered him to his
chair
Adams refused kept on his feet hours on
end his few allies including the
anti-slavery champion Joshua Giddings of
Ohio gathered protectively by his side
the leaders of the slave factions got up
from their seats to hover nearby lest
they miss a word of the old man's
increasingly quavery voice and of course
also to throw those insults at him that
weld had described and now Adams pulled
another page from a sheaf of papers that
he held close to his chest
and he turned to the speaker and he said
the following he said I hold in my hand
the memorial which is to say petition of
Benjamin Emerson and forty-five other
citizens of Haverhill in the state of
Massachusetts praying Congress to adopt
immediate measures for the peaceful
dissolution of the Union of these states
the petitioners no longer wished to see
the resources of the free states drained
as they put it for the benefit of the
slave states
well the slave aqua sea which is the
word Adams used to describe those people
had been waiting for a sufficient
provocation to move against Adams Adams
had now provided it and Henri wise of
Virginia now rose to propose a
resolution to censure the former
president very grave punishment Adams
replied good and you should think about
that word he said good he wasn't
thinking about the trial that was to
come he wasn't thinking about the
possible humiliation of being censured
he was delighted it was a war that he
had sought and he had gained
and he looked forward to it in an uproar
the house then adjourned
let me now back up a little bit and
explain how Adams had come to this point
in his quite extraordinary career so
like virtually all New Englanders Adams
was profoundly opposed to slavery and
considered it a gross violation both of
American Republican principles and of
Christian principles as well but he also
considered slavery to be in effect a
settled issue the Constitution had been
silent on it states were free to do as
they wish there was essentially nothing
that the federal government could do or
from Adams his point of view
should do about slavery his views only
began to change in 1820 1820 was the era
of what we now call the Missouri
Compromise and what happened then was
there were then 22 states 11 free and 11
slave and Missouri petitioned to gain
entrance to the Union as a slave state
which of course would have destabilized
the balance and that provoked a huge
debate also Missouri was far enough
north that there was a strong case to be
made that it should be entered as a free
state because all the other free states
were at that latitude or above and a
tremendous debate broke out in the
Congress and Adams of course at this
time he was Secretary of State
he had no no place in that debate but he
he watched that debate and he felt the
debate was being dominated by the
southerners who then had many highly
regarded eloquent speakers and it was
deeply frustrating to him they wished
that he could speak but he couldn't
instead he raised the issue in the
cabinet the cabinet at that time
consisted almost entirely of southerners
of slaveholders this was the cabin of
James Monroe and Adams was slapped down
afterwards she took a walk down
Pennsylvania Avenue probably only a few
blocks from where we are today with John
Calhoun it was the Secretary of War John
Calhoun would go on to become the great
ideologue and intellectual justifier of
slavery but Adams had a lot of regard
for Calhoun Calhoun was a brilliant man
and Adams at that time considered
Calhoun to be a person of tremendous
intellectual integrity and Adams
continued to talk as was his want and
Calhoun listened to him and said we know
those are those are very noble
principles but where I come from we
think those principles only apply to
white people not to black people and
Adams went home that night iris had a
diary he kept a diary every day of his
life
quite extraordinary for me a great
resource for someone in my position and
he would write down sometimes almost
verbatim the conversations that happened
that day if he thought they were
important so he he went back home at
some point began to write and he was
thinking about the fact that a man is
gifted as calhoun whom he admired so
much could sincerely hold views that
Adams found repellent and at least to
himself evidently false there was a
larger truth in this one that had not
presented itself to Adams until now
transcribing his train of thought as it
came to him Adams wrote that the
practice of slavery taints the very
sources of moral principle it perverts
human reason and reduces men endowed
with logical powers to maintain that
slavery is sanctioned by the Christian
religion the impression produced upon my
mind by the progress of this discussion
is that the bargain between freedom and
slavery contained in the constitution of
the United States is morally and
politically vicious this was an
astonishing conclusion for a man who had
been raised for the earliest moment of
consciousness to regard Union as the
supreme good who had devoted his career
was a diplomat and a politician to
offending the integrity of the United
States against foreign and domestic
threats Adams was a perky and
conservative who feared and abhorred
revolutionary upheaval yet he had
reasoned himself into a into a position
that was too honest to reason himself
out of later that year was the
negotiations over Missouri continued the
state of Legislature passed a law that
banned free people of color from the
state literally said even if you were a
free person you cannot come into the
state of you're a person of color and
this enraged Adams and I think maybe
kind of burst the last stays that were
holding in his his deepest feelings he
saw this as a provocation to the free
states of course but also to the very
cause of human freedom and a friend of
his a colleague came to talk to him
about it and and Adams then in his diary
records what he said to this man and
I'll just read you a little piece of his
quite astonishing so thinking about the
slaves and indeed thinking about not
just to enslavement the racism in a way
that I think is surprising for a man
from his place he didn't know any black
people the only ones he knew were
servants and yet there was an active
sympathy he understood and this is what
he wrote Rick and defenseless as they
are so much the more sacred is the
obligation of the legislators of the
states to which they belong to defend
their lawful rights and I would defend
them should the dissolution of the Union
be the consequence for it would not be
the defense it would be the violation of
their rights to which all the
consequences would be imputable and if
the dissolution of the Union must come
let it come from no other cause than
this if slavery be the destined sword in
the hand of the destroying angel which
is to sever the ties of the Union the
same sword will cut it's under will cut
in sunder I'm sorry the bonds of slavery
itself
a dissolution of the Union for the cause
of slavery would be followed by a
servile war in the slaveholding States
combined with a war between the two
severed portions of the Union it seems
to me that its result must be the
exterior paint of slavery from this
whole continent and calamitous and
desolating as this course of events in
its progress must be so glorious would
be its final issue that as God shall
judge me I dare not say that it is to be
denied so that was Adams in 1820 writing
to himself not not speaking to anybody
else not saying this and indeed as
present for the remainder of his tenure
as Secretary of State as president he
said nothing about slavery either in his
diary or to others it remained a
non-issue for him it was a it was a kind
of buried issue that obviously remained
inside him but it was not the focus of
his career so after he was beaten for
re-election by Andrew Jackson in 1828
and returned home he then went back to
Congress in 1831 he's the he was the
first president to ever return to
Congress and he remains to this day
the only president to have served in the
House of Representatives after the
presidency by now an anti-slavery
movement had begun in the United States
by 1835 activists had begun preparing
and sending to the very few sympathetic
congressmen petitions calling for an end
to the slave trade or the abolition of
slavery in the District of Columbia over
which the federal government had
jurisdiction
that's when southerners began to call
for the gag order now Adams was too
harsh a realist to believe that in an
open public debate southerners would
vomit
and agreed to its abolition he did not
think that was possible he had said to
himself and he still believed that only
civil war would bring an end to
and now when it was a reality he could
not say out loud what he had said to
himself he could not bring him to say
that the idea of civil war was
acceptable something which only the most
extreme radical abolitionists would
adopt so he was in a quandary he didn't
have doubts about the merits of the
question he didn't know how to get there
he didn't know what he is a congressman
could do I think he thought that the
petition issue was a way to force into
public debate the question of slavery
and therefore at least expose the full
horror of the practice I don't think he
thought that that would in slavery but
he thinks I think he thought it was the
best he could do but beyond that Adams
was what we would now call a First
Amendment absolutist and that question
for him took the form of petitions now
it's not easy for us to understand now
what now why petitions would matter so
much but remember at that time there
were no lobbies there were no special
interest groups there were no write-in
campaigns of no of promisee no internet
there was no way that citizens could
have their voices heard except through
the act of voting petitions were the way
that they could do that and in Adams own
mind the word petition also had a kind
of additional resonance even the most
humble servant can petition the king or
they or the Emir in even the most
dictatorial government how could you
deny the citizen of a democracy the
right to a petition so for Adams these
two issues the issue of the petition and
a free speech and the issue of slavery
converged to make a thing so powerful
that it would seize him really for the
rest of his time in Congress and
therefore for the rest of his life and
so from that time forward this became a
kind of a mania an obsession for Adams
and he was prepared to stand up when
when nobody else was indeed it's worth
saying that many other men who shared
Adams his views felt that it was foolish
reckless pointless to wage a battle over
this Congress because you'd never
succeed the Congress was really
and aided by slaveholders thanks in part
to these so-called three-fifths
compromise in in the Constitution
talking about slavery would achieve
nothing it would just gum up the works
of Congress and so other people wouldn't
do it and Adam said I don't care I'll do
it by myself and so in every new session
Adams would present petitions the
southerners would vote the gag order
Adams would try to get around it fight
would ensue until in 1837 Adams
presented a petition that purported to
come from slaves themselves which was an
unspeakable violation from the point of
view of the slave owners as he knew the
idea that slaves might have the
opportunity the right to petition
Congress if it had that right what other
rights might they have so the fact is
the petition was a fraud Adams knew it
was a fraud it probably was sent to set
him up because they somebody knew he
would present it and not only that the
petition didn't call for the end of
slavery it was the opposite the petition
from these alleged slaves called for the
preservation of slavery because slaves
liked slavery that's what the petition
said but Adams didn't reveal that when
he presented the petition this is still
back in 1837
so all the other congressmen knew was
that he was presenting a petition from
slaves presumably demanding an end to
slavery so Adams defended this thing he
said of course he would present a
petition from a slave he said I would
present a petition from a horse or a dog
if it had the power of speech and a
writing okay this was the first
confrontation this provoked the first
attempt to censure Adams which I won't
describe but it went on for several
weeks
Adams dominated the debate he decimated
the opposition and by the time he was
done only 22 of the 238 members in the
House voted for century okay now we come
forward five years when the memory of
that humiliation perhaps has faded and
so by this time there is a sizable
abolitionist movement and there are
other abolitionists or anti-slavery
legislators in Congress
so this group the activists that
congressman they all room together in
one room a house was called abolition
house Theodore wealth great anti-slavery
horror and writer essayist took a desk
in the Library of Congress and served as
the group's head of research others saw
to the printing and distribution of the
anti-slavery tracts but Adams was the
weed of the group in Congress nobody
questioned that and he said to weld that
he would present petitions that would
set the slaveholders in a blaze and that
is what he did On January 21st 1842 now
of course the southerners had also
learned from their mistakes of five
years ago so this time they cost as a
group they said let's appoint a chief
prosecutor and so they chose Thomas
marshal Thomas Marshall was the nephew
of John Marshall the great and revered
Supreme Court Chief Justice he was also
a highly regarded lawyer and order a
moderate a member of the Whig party and
so the perfect person to represent their
point of view so that didn't simply seem
like slavery against anti-slavery so
several days later I think was probably
January 25th Marshall began to speak and
it was an astonishing spectacle this was
an immense event crowds filled the
galleries of the house long before the
noon opening of the session
Giddings noted that foreign ministers
Itachi's and privileged persons filled
the lobbies in the outer space within
the hall and outside the bar the speaker
called on Marshall who read a resolution
to censure madness in his version though
he had raised the stakes considerably
whereas he asserted a dissolution of the
Union necessarily implies the
destruction of the Constitution the
overthrow of the Republic and the
violation of the legislators own oath
the petition Adams had presented
compelled the members to pray
to themselves and involved the crime of
high treason Adams deserved expulsion
censure said Marshall was an act of
grace and mercy this would prove to be a
catastrophic overreach on Marshalls part
Marshall delivered an indictment he
prefaced by long expressions of regard
for Adams himself and forms his family
and for their place in history he
therefore professed himself astounded
when such a revered figure presented to
the house so monstrous a document and
not only presented that document but
sought to have it referred to committee
thus leading to the conclusion that the
dissolution of the Union was a fair
subject to be considered by the house
marshals professions of neutrality and
his rhetorical command had cheered his
colleagues and left Adams supporters
depressed in a corresponding degree
getting his robe both sides waited with
excruciating anticipation for the old
man's response with all eyes on him
Adams rose slowly looking about him at
friend and foe and at last said to the
speaker it is no part of my intention to
reply to the gentleman from Kentucky at
this time that was a startling remark
what then was his intention I call Adams
went on for the reading of the first
paragraph of the Declaration of
Independence the clerk began to leave
when in the course of human events when
he slowed uncertain where to stop Adams
cried proceed proceed the court
continued whenever any form of
government becomes destructive of those
ends it is the right of the people to
alter or abolish it and then an atom's
order came to a stop at it is their
right it is their duty to throw off such
government John Quincy Adams his father
had played a central role in writing the
Declaration of Independence John Quincy
himself had been very much alive at the
time his adversary Thomas Marshall was a
young pup of 40
animus was reminding his audience which
had come to see him as a fanatic and a
monomaniac of his own connection to the
nation's founding documents and
principles and more than that of just
what those principles were was it high
treason he now went on to advocate the
dissolution of the government never mind
the decoration had been written to
justify the dissolution of colonial
Dominion the real danger to the Republic
Adams continued came not from
petitioners but from slaveholders there
was a concerted system and purpose to
destroy all the principles of civil
liberty in the free states the right of
habeas corpus and the right of filed by
jury
we're at risk so of course was the right
of petition welled admittedly the most
bias of spectators wrote that old Nestor
had demonstrated a calm fearlessness and
Majesty that furnished the highest
illustration of the moral sublime that I
ever witnessed in a popular secular
assembly now Henry wise rose to deliver
a rebuttal wise was an intemperate man
he didn't have Marshalls degree of
restraint and he delivered a fiery
blistering ugly attack on Adams
personally on Adams father what he
called the house of Braintree that was
where they were from very violent Adams
kept his cool for two days so when Adams
finally rose to speak
he made a very ingenious argument about
Virginia where Henry Wise was from which
was also designed again to remind
everyone who John Quincy Adams was it
grieved him from the very soul to see
these propositions come from Virginia if
there was a state in this Union for
which even now we felt an attachment
greater than to any other except his
native state it was to Virginia